I feel like I'm burning all my taste
buds yeah what a flame torch
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by lil yachty he's a
grammy-nominated platinum selling artist
one of the biggest rappers in the game
and he can pick up his third studio
album nothing to prove vailable now
Nadia
welcome to the show so I know that you
have very particular taste when it comes
to food you have a diet that consists of
pizza corn dogs and chicken nuggets but
you're extending for us today
how are you at spicy food I don't eat
spicy food
never had a sauce in my life in your
entire life ever you know you're the
first guest in the history of this show
and maybe the first person I've ever met
in my life who's never eaten hot sauce
ever I'm excited as I wanted to do it
[Music]
you're right
grill out 6-piece hmm this is small
spice mm-hmm as we touched on your intro
you have some very particular
sensibilities when it comes to food on a
live stream that you did with ninja
actually heard you say that you've never
had a fruit or vegetable in your life
but the thing I'm most curious about can
you take me through the mechanics of
eating pizza every single day since
second grade well my mom worked you know
when she came home at the work she just
I should be tired
so usually for the most part she just go
get a pizza in it and then I didn't
notice realizing I ordered that it was
literally almost every day that it's
just what I eat it's just what I'm used
to is what I know you know like it's
just my life well you know there seems
to be an arms race these days with all
these pizzas outrageous ones ones that
have crust made out of ramen noodles or
dessert style pizzas with Nutella and
marshmallows so what I want to do is
show you some crazy examples of pizzas
and I just wonder if maybe you're into
it maybe you're not maybe some of these
you've even tried so this first one is a
$2,000 pizza it's made with black
truffles caviar and squid ink dough
covered in gold flakes even gold flakes
$2,000 for that pizza I should yes but
if I got I got boiling corn flakes with
a bunch [ __ ] in it I know why people
think like since they raise the price on
is make us you might want to try it all
right up next we have a Mexican pizza
from Tony boloney's in New Jersey it's
topped with 16 tacos and guacamole
that's though oh you talking so I
wouldn't try it but the licks dough
looks cool this is a pop rocks and
cotton candy pizza that's fire
definitely would try to you're into that
yeah that makes my cavities tingle
you don't even wait you just go you just
going I got just like I watch now watch
how the slow other people do it then you
do it so fast I kill his insides must be
scrambled yeah do you have no idea yeah
no idea god bless you alright I'm
curious about your perspective when it
comes to the internet and its ability to
make a song pop and if you want to talk
about examples maybe Kelly on fox
featuring one night in that video or you
have Shiggy who's credited with really
helping Drake's in my feelings get
catapulted to a billboard number-one hit
the thing about that and I feel like
rappers don't they feel to realize that
you can't force it I've when Kelly on
fox who I've always given credited to no
made that video that went viral but one
night would stop lighting all that I've
never heard of him I never met him
before
I couldn't pay him to do that he didn't
know what was gonna blow up it was just
like some [ __ ] he did and it any massive
along with shitty Drake didn't know
shaggy you might know it was we didn't
ask him to do that labels didn't asked
him to do that like ask it what a song
featuring and it may help you realize
false a good song or visual make you may
help you realize but I never knew how
good the song was you know it's it's
weird you know I don't know but I do
know that these are amazing that was so
good you like that one
Wow I'm sorry brother that was I don't I
don't you much snow sands oh and I want
some [ __ ] is good and knew was like what
is use it's a whole new world for you
yeah yeah no this is really good
oh my goodness but I'll try it I was
excused about how sauce hmm new ground
breaking new ground over here I was
always curious about know like how does
hot sauce work like Ron I bought used to
when I like if you touched it was it hot
you know like like I didn't know if it
was on tongue situation or in the throat
situation like I just never knew but I
like the second eye a bit that something
happened hell broke loose
yeah see once described winning a battle
royale has given you as much joy as
losing your virginity I know that you
take gaming very seriously so I'm
curious is there a game or franchise
that you think is best for sampling and
hip-hop beats without a thought Super
Mario they make their own sound
you know like 2k like mad and they just
get music from other artists but they
orchestrate their own music and it has
this organic natural sound it just like
sounds like Mario when you think of all
the times have squared off against fans
or randos on the internet with the
headset are there any stories that stand
out actually for the first time not too
long ago I got a person who liked like
an [ __ ] right usually people are
actually pretty happy for the first time
for the first time when I was playing
again I was long I knew it like dude you
[ __ ] suck like I hate you like your
music is [ __ ] I was like refreshed I
said this Xbox is supposed to be you
know
[Music]
you just get straight into the men's
Savage
all these flavors yeah never seen the
cartoon why you see the steam come out
of your nose mm-hmm feel it no but it's
good like it but the crazy it's so like
it's such heat and you don't take like I
wouldn't taste anything but heat but it
seems like you're taking to the hot
sauce a little bit at least the server I
still don't and I'll ever eat it again
but darn good walk so your career is
taking off way beyond music you're one
of the most broke wikiproject what is I
mean I I lost no no no no there's no
rules it's not like the Olympics it's
just it's here if you need it it's here
if you want it but maybe right it
doesn't make you a podcast we won't do
this we're here what do you remember
about modeling kanye west easy season
three at Madison Square Garden
that's the first big thing I ever did on
so in the beginning it was a curtain
over us and we stand on the pillars and
I was in the back I was in the you know
the like the lineup I was on the ferry I
was actually at the very back house last
one and behind everybody and last minute
the lady profuse the producer was
talking somebody about the tongue in the
club is like no you need to go up the
other semis I was really just me a nose
I say hey um my hairs right don't you
think I should be knit for it and she
looked at me say get you go yeah I'm
gonna do how to standing back he looked
at me crazy enough I ran to the front
just did it right before him and went
off no standing and I never sat down and
it was cool you know and from there
that's my career started
so this next one is louis calientes all
right yeah do you ever encourage
segments on our show called explain that
grammar we do a deep dive on our guests
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop again I'll show you the picture
then you tell me the bigger story does
that sound good
okay all right laptop please how you
doing my man it's hot
hanging in there a little bit hi welcome
to this show
welcome to the hot sauce world over here
does that give you guys your tongue hang
out in the air would be a little bit
better yeah I got it
what can you tell the people about your
21st birthday at sparkles family fun
center between the Mariachi band and the
Ferrari it looked like a good time
that's the best that was probably the
best day of my life man I never had ever
had I've had a party a couple parties in
my life blue always been scared to have
a party because you never know it won't
come you know my mother my managers and
my mom team I label to just made sure
that I really had a great time I worked
so hard and I did so much and like it's
rare to I feel like anybody ever cares
you know like I don't know it's just
it's just you kid it's a lot but when
that day man I felt so much love and it
was crazy I was that's I don't forever
be the best day of my life where do you
think you got a better fit off the
tuxedo jacket at Jimmy Kimmel or the
white on white at the Met Gala that was
Jeremy Scott yeah I'm such as I've been
such a fan of James got going out there
designing it's so nice and he chose me
to come
Met Gala which is a big deal mm-hmm you
know for me to be able to be there and
just me so dope like a slave master you
know it was excellent I looked like the
baddest slave master of all time
it was so cool I felt good and I had
this eyeglass in my pocket
I was either slave master or the
Kentucky Fried Chicken guy bill Colonel
Sanders also slave masters like exactly
probably also nice exactly I was another
one of highlights my life and I just
like wow I've done something you know so
it was good it was funny you ready to
move on yeah I appreciate the break you
give me before we go to the next one
there's a pace two hot ones you know
sometimes
[Music]
Essam Clark and Hopkins does it ever
faze you
so I'm human you know I'm no superhero
the sauces they hit me but what it
really comes down to is it's better than
having a real job word so I just hold it
down over here
that's how I think sometimes I get upset
at certain things like man I could
definitely be doing something else so
you know I have my little fitting then I
get to it so be grateful be helpful
mm-hmm so for casual observers and
hip-hop media I think one of the most
amusing flare-ups in recent memory was
yachty versus the old guard whether it
was calling up 97 to go toe-to-toe with
Ebro or of course that iconic showdown
with Joe Budden on the set of an
everyday struggle no this [ __ ] was so
hot
Irene here the people you name but I
know my beefs so I know well as far as
Ebro learned a lot from that situation
oh [ __ ] to him because I learned how to
deal with people how to deal with those
types of situations and I learned a lot
about myself so yeah I mean it made me
go hari like I started doing my my
starting my deals and campaigns and
started working on all these
it's like he leaves and come back right
it's a it's like careful around your
eyes eonni uh yeah I don't want to make
the problem work yo it's like it sneaks
mm-hmm back yeah I knew me be bro wasn't
cool or to the public and and I called
him like yo let's meet again you know I
know my first freestyle wasn't the best
I won't do it again you know and whose
other person your name Joe Budden Joe
Budden I'm me and Joe Brennan got into
it we like all this function I don't
want to hear me in the [ __ ] Club I
don't think it's being followed [ __ ]
said they don't like John and that one
you know I really I look like the like
the good guy now cuz he was just like
hey you know like he looked really
bitter you know but I didn't have a
problem with Joe Budden I never did
it's love I get so much love I don't get
bothered by it know whether you in a 360
or not I want you to appreciate the
culture they changed your life it took
you from college dorm room even [ __ ]
all of the noodles I want you who's
well-spoken it articulates himself well
my [ __ ] see ya
[Music]
firewater I was too big of a bite
oh good enough that was gonna be a
game-changer
[Music]
let's find it my man unfriended my man
now this is the devil snack yeah oh my
mother burning yeah oh alright
little yadi will over the last couple of
years the city of Atlanta it's had these
watershed moments from its artists
dominating the Billboard charts to
donald glover stacking golden globes so
what i want to do is give you a few
hallmarks of the atlanta brand and you
can weigh in on the perception versus
the reality
Hotlanta is that something that people
from atlanta say or is that just
something for idiots who've never
stepped foot in georgia how lame is some
like 1990 1980s Freaknik type [ __ ] that
my mom used to say when she was young it
wasn't my mom and they just don't say
how lana know people always talk about
how atlanta has the best strip clubs is
that true mm-hmm thank you buddy but
naked yeah it's awesome Houston has an
isolationist Joe goes to Tim's are
synonymous with New York if you go to
the DMV maybe you'll see New Balance 993
ker that's quintessentially Atlanta
airforces yeah then some and then your
driveway has been getting pretty crowded
lately what do you think is your most
Atlanta car my okay my Dodge Charger
Hellcat and though it's just like some
Atlanta [ __ ] you know you don't really
see a lot of [ __ ] getting Hellcats
like how we do its know anything for a
fact
[Music]
god yeah
this is a very brave thing that you're
doing
oh that's the most high hide hottest
[ __ ] you've ever had in your limb my
entire realm of breathing air until
possibly now does she look so scary yeah
and this is the one people really be
freaking out over like McMichael sorrows
like this is the one it was I can attest
[ __ ] it we here we're here man yeah here
I'm sticky like I want it I'm okay
[Music]
yeah
Oh
oh the real baptism by fire looking at a
changed man over here and yadi it would
not be a first be feast
interview unless we did a swan dive into
the lyrics of your latest project so
what I want to do let's take a few
highlights often nothing2prove and you
can give me the deeper mission of water
my behind the lyrics okay this first one
is off your song everything good
everything right
I just spent eight thousand to play Sega
used to be broke using food stamps at
bodegas what's the story behind spending
eight grand to play second I won't
answer that question so where manga
[Music]
yeah sky who makes its arcade systems he
puts every single system ever made owner
is ice cream oh my god
careful around your eyes this is so hot
I feel like I'm burning all my taste
buds yeah what a flame torch
oh you gotta be [ __ ] up if you think
I'm finishing I am still trying to
recover how did God should've stayed on
the right side closer to handle my body
I'm not even being dramatic right now no
I know it's a whole thing and yadi
you're a newborn - the hot sauce game
you know and nobody there first time
eating hot sauce should do it on hot
ones but you're just a brave person so
I'm off is [ __ ] on fire
[Music]
this is an intense interview dog mm-hmm
there's a way I'm gonna make it to the
end of there
I'm okay with that I'm done
Oh Rani ha
[Music]
nobody is acting up right now like it's
just doing crazy things when I'm sorry
I lost you did not lose there's no such
thing as losing it's not a competition
you push yourself as hard as you can go
and then we let the chips fall where
they may
this is the last deaf okay
we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last way you don't have to
if you don't want to loli Adi
[Music]
as long with you
alright yadi here we are at the last
stop aboard the Hot Sauce pain train
we've taken on the wings of death eight
wings up eight wings down to storm the
board but nothing to sneeze at and you
still have a smile on your face sort of
which is very little yadi you've been
someone who's been described as
relentlessly optimistic a light a breath
of fresh air so as we close it out i'm
curious what is your advice for the
people who should be living with their
head in the clouds rather than those who
are wallowing in the mud so my body is
torching just be yourself man no my gosh
it is important [ __ ] what people think
bro it's hard to get to the love with a
[ __ ] what people think you know because
you know generally unless you are
completely satisfied with your life
completely it's hard to disagree [ __ ]
the people thing bro know how you can
live your life but you know well that's
the truth if I've ever heard it and look
at you little yachty first time trying
hot sauce and it's here on hot ones
there's nothing I'd rather do than draw
up the red carpet for you my man this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
[Music]
well nothing approved just dropped on
Austrian services make sure you go get
it if you love it I appreciate it I
[Music]
don't know that's all I got for you
shall we no joke no I no joke about this
show okay I'm almost with you take your
time I'm an hmm hey what's going on
spice Lords I know you're wondering why
is he shaking that bottle why is he
shaking that bottle it's because I'm
excited to announce that the last dab
products is available now the last dab
with chocolate pepper ax and pepper X
you've seen your favorite celebrities
dab and wings on the show and now you
can dab your wings at home Keaton is
calm heat nice calm to order who
appreciates you spice Lords me